Flying through the night, I watch over this world.
A silent guardian.
A watchful protector.
A dark knight.
I'm...
Okay fine, so I'm not Batman.
I'm just a bat.
But like Batman, I'm often misunderstood.
People think I'm scary, strange and dangerous.
If they only knew my story though, I'd be cheered as a hero.
Vampire bats can be a great help to humans.
A chemical known as desmoteplase found in vampire bat's saliva...
...helps break down blood clots and is being tested by recovering stroke victims.
Of the remaining thousand plus species of bats, about 70% feed on insects.
These bats help control the real vampires: mosquitoes,...
...whose nasty bites are not just annoying, but spread diseases like West Nile Virus.
Batman might want to keep his identity secret,...
...but a great way to help real bats is by continuing to learn about them...
...and spreading the truth that they are real heroes...
...even if their good deeds are often unseen.